Another big perk of getting a fucking divorce
after being a stay at home mom
and then getting to have your own house.
You get to design shit yourself.
Super fun to have your own shit and your own space.
I get to like put plants everywhere.
And I get to have my like
fucking bold pattern couch with my solid color pillows.
And like, I don't ask nobody's fucking permission for the shit.
Do you know what I mean? I would have never.
I just.
I love it. I get to love my house,
I get to love my life. I get to be the mom I wanted to be.
I get to make the rules of the house. Like, I love this bear.
It's not worth it to stay in a marriage just cause you have kids.
Because then
your kids don't even fucking get to know you for who you are.
So they grow up thinking you're one thing,
but you're not. And then they get to know you as their adults.
Like, I don't know,
I just wasn't willing to sacrifice my whole entire life
because I suddenly became a wife.
If I didn't get to be a person,
then I just. I'll leave that situation.
And I fucking hope you do too.